[Music]
from one legendary performer
to another
[Applause]
a single song from dream girls made both
women's real life dreams come true
[Music]
i'm telling you you go to movies when
jennifer i just said you're the best
man no no no no way
i promise you'll be sitting in a movie
theater like this
dream girls was a broadway sensation
from its debut
in 1981 and the breakout star was
jennifer holliday
who brought down the house night after
night with and i am telling you
and then here i come this girl from
texas and i sing
one song one song in a two-hour show
it wasn't until dream girls that i said
i don't know i've got gotta
i guess i'm gonna be in show business
holliday won a tony award for the role
she also nabbed a grammy for the show
stopper too
i hoped that they were really gonna call
my name and that's what they did
holiday credits the smash hit for making
her a star
the show as well as the song
was all a blessing because no one would
know who i am if it wasn't for dream
girls
and 20 years later another star was shot
into the stratosphere
well i was a little nervous but more
anxious than anything
after losing american idol jennifer
hudson became the next
to make the iconic song her own a dream
she actually spoke into existence with
e.t
i want to do some theater i want to be
china for holiday and dream girls
i want to act yep that really happened
and just two years after that interview
hudson landed the role of effie white
in the big screen adaptation of dream
girls
this is beyond my dreams i feel like i'm
dreaming
[Music]
the pressure was on for hudson to make
her version of the song
just as memorable as holidays we didn't
film the scene that one scene until the
end of filming
so the whole time through filming this
was that was what was on my country it's
like oh god
everything else is going good but when i
get to that the then 24 year old actress
was worried about not being able to cry
during the take
but she surprised even director bill
condon with what she brought to the
scene
so when it came the time came as soon as
i hit the stage
it was one point where bill had to stop
the cameras and say
she has to get herself together that is
way too much tears i was up there like
i couldn't get a word out and and before
i
it just just came i don't know where it
came from and when hudson saw the movie
at the premiere
the whole experience still seemed like a
dream
the only thing was when i'm telling you
came up
i scooted down and then chill like oh
god here you come i want to hop up and
say okay
just just stop just stop it's just a
joke please i'm not ready
because everybody's waiting for that
moment and i'm like i didn't expect it
to come so soon
hudson went on to win a golden globe a
sag award and an
oscar for the role i'm grateful to
american idol for
being the vehicle for me to be seen for
this so thank you
i mean that wasn't intended for me to
win you know this was meant for jennifer
hudson
and these two epic journeys collided in
2007
when the jennifers performed a duet of
and i am telling you at the bet awards
we're trying girls